and that's the problem because I'm sure
that years ago you weren't thinking like
this all of a sudden you start listening
that's what they want you to do that's
what they want and the fact that they're
confusing the children as well yeah that
is what is wrong because I'm a mother of
two do you understand she's a child to
me considering my son you know as far as
I'm concerned they're starting confusing
the children already otherwise if she
doesn't know who she is what a woman is
then what chance do we spend for your
children my grandchildren and that's
what it needs to stop because they've
started with like they're older they get
into you and now they want to get into
the school yeah so according to how
you're thinking it should be okay to go
into the schools and to be teaching I
think when the schools will be up
earlier and it was on the news that they
didn't want to teach them sex education
I can't remember what's the children as
young as five I want to do about
transgender and all these different
genders with sex education it's a joke
for school children